sandra let's bring in lieutenant general
keith kellogg former national security
advisor to vice president pence and the
co-chairman of the american first policy
institute center for american security
we're at the touch screen general this
is the overview of ukraine and we can
see that the amount of red on the screen
that represents the areas under russian
control is beginning to increase
potentially here down in the south of
the country where forces coming up from
crimea have now taken the city of
kerason they're also moving toward
mariupol here in the northeast mariupol
according to the deputy mayor there has
been under bombardment for some 26 hours
there also
apparently are reports of fighting in
and around the area of en erhodar which
is where the zaparisia nuclear power
plant is that's the biggest nuclear
power plant in all of europe and then
general as far as we know the plan
ultimately for russian forces would be
to sort of hook
west and then uh west south west to
surround the city of odessa
that would give them control of the
entire black sea coast of of ukraine
what kind of an advantage would get that
give them as they then try to move on uh
through the rest of the country here
you know john well thanks for having me
we'll look odessa is important it's the
third largest city and if they take out
they've got sea access i think that what
we're actually seeing is actually the uh
not the beginning of the end but the end
of the beginning we're looking at new
stages and the stages that we're going
to watch and we should watch very
carefully is uh putin going into kiev
and kharkov and and taking those cities
down by massive barbarian barbar
bombardment look years ago uh when i was
in europe i took a special team into
sarajevo when gerald morione was there
with the u.n protection force the
enforcer and when he got on the ground
and was watching
heavy artillery just demolish the city
of sarajevo from the heights around
around the city and came back into into
european command and said look get ready
we're going to go in there and everybody
told me now we're not going to do that
it's not going to happen well we went in
and i think when you start to see the
images of heavy bombardment coming in on
especially the capital city i think the
the people of the world are going to say
well this may have gone too far and i
think that earlier comment about a
no-fly zone on the western uh part of
ukraine may start to take effect and
that may i understand what brett said
earlier about this kind of raises the
game sure and raising the odds but look
sooner or later the people of the world
are going to say look this has gone way
too far remember when the bosnian civil
war ended we took melodic she was the
senior general
of the uh of the bosnian serbs and
kuratich who was the president and we
brought him up on war crime charges and
you're reaching a point now where that
the bombardment of a city like that of
kiev is in fact a war crime so we're at
the start of a brand new phase and it's
going to be really interesting to watch
how the world reacts to you when you
start seeing these video images of a
city a modern city being destroyed by a
predator nation
of russia and how are they going to
react and i'm not too sure that the
jury's out on that and if i was
president biden i would have taken my
advisors put them in a room and said you
come up with every option you've got the
to the worst to the best and and
basically like they do in poker this may
be all in
yeah well you know this idea of a no-fly
zone certainly is something that keeps
getting pushed by ukrainian uh
parliament members but they want a
no-fly zone over the entire country one
other thing that i wanted to run by you
real quickly is i don't know if you saw
ambassador volcker and we talked with
bret baer about this just a second ago
but here's the convoy that is uh you
know this is this is just a small part
of it and this goes for 40 miles
northwest of kiev up all the way up to
the belarusian border ambassador volcker
was suggesting that we've got some a-10
warthogs that are about to be
decommissioned why don't we just send
them over to ukraine i mean can you
imagine the shooting gallery that an a10
pilot would have in in this environment
but again like a no-fly zone is that a
provocation that leads to other things
that you don't want to have happen
yeah you know i'm looking at i bet you
there's some u.s air force pilots out
there salivating and wanting to change
their citizenship to ukrainian right
about now so you get in with the a-10
warthogs look we did that in world war
ii with the eagle squadron in england
when we sent american pilots in to fly
for the raf we did it in china when we
had the flying tigers there were
american volunteers you may see
something like that i mean that is an
impressive target to try to take out but
sooner or later we're gonna have to make
some hard choices and the president is
gonna have to do that he's gonna have to
be what i said earlier he's going to
have to become a wartime president
whether he likes it or not we're kind of
there all right general kellogg we'll
see where this goes it looks like it's
going to take a lot longer than a lot of
people thought it would we'll have you
around for a while general keith kellogg
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else